a company called ocean gates  successfully reached more than 13,000  feet underwater using a privately built  submersible that's the depth of the  Titanic the team spent six months  perfecting the deep dive off the coast  of the Bahamas ocean gate founder  Stockton rush completed the daring  mission in about seven hours I can't  express what that has meant to me and  what it means to imagine the great  things we're gonna explore and find in  the ocean in the years to come trips to  the Titanic will be available to  researchers and so-called citizen  explorers the company says its  underwater vehicle will open access to  half of the world's ocean waters and  seems to be next worry you've got to  have big bucks 250 to go up in space 100  to go the Titanic but it's it's a  passion for a lot of people it is and if  it were free I'd rather go up yeah  that's interesting let me sit here weigh  in